it's a friday p-f-t-o-t with no pft live
to anchor
the show at least not on nbcsn we
stepped aside for the rugby world cup
pft live on nbc sports radio went
forward as usual thanks to daryn
gansharine williams and tom curran for
joining me for the three-hour radio show
some of the big highlights right now in
the national football league i want to
start with the thursday night game
yeah it was kind of a boring game but we
learned some things about the jaguars we
learned some things about the titans and
we're going to continue to learn more
one week at a time as the season unfolds
gardner minshew ii the early darling of
the nfl getting his first career win in
his first home start as the quarterback
for the jacksonville jaguars everybody
is praising this guy but let's keep one
thing in mind and first of all i think
he's doing a great job i think it's
spectacular to see the jaguars find a
young quarterback who can come in and
get it done after all those years of
a guy not getting it done in the form of
blake portals but remember with any new
quarterback four to six weeks of game
film is what defensive coordinators need
to begin to figure out what the guy does
that doesn't mean all of a sudden he's
going to fall off a cliff what it means
is he will be facing more elaborate game
plans that are designed specifically to
address what he does well and to force
him toward the things that maybe he
doesn't do quite so well efforts to
confuse him with different looks and
whatnot to make him
play like the rookie that he is and
there's a looming dilemma out there for
the jacksonville jaguars and at some
point i would expect doug maron the
coach of the team to mention the 100
rule as it relates to
starting quarterback nick foles because
foles has a broken collar bone and if
gardner minshew the second continues to
play at a high level
they're going to give that collar bone a
little extra time to heal and foles
won't play until he is
100 and when will he be 100
at some point after he's truly 100
percent and gardner minshew the second
cools off until then look for foals to
continue to be the guy he's always been
he's not going to clamor to play he's
not going to cause problems he's not
going to be passive aggressive he's
going to support whoever is playing and
do everything he can to keep himself
ready to go the difference is because
now nick foles is the carson wentz and
gardner minshew is the nick foles but
nick falls doesn't have the body of work
in jacksonville that wentz had in
philadelphia it was easier to flip back
to carson wentz once wentz was healthy
it's going to be harder to put falls
back out on the field because each
passing week we're seeing more and more
from gardner minshew the second assuming
he continues to play well if he doesn't
play well it's a no-brainer as soon as
foles is healthy he's back on the field
so keep an eye on how that develops
because we get into mid to late november
nick foles collarbone gets closer and
closer to 100 percent
maybe just maybe they continue to ride
the hot hand by saying we're protecting
nick foles against the possible re-break
of that injured collarbone
the tennessee titans are eventually
going to have some decisions to make at
the quarterback position maybe not
during the season maybe maybe after the
season or most definitely at some point
before free agency in 2020 because
marcus mariota is in the last year of
his rookie deal and
in the first half of last night's game
he did not look good at all six of 16.
at one point ryan tan hill had his
helmet on it prompted reporters to ask
coach mike frable after the game how
close was tannehill to being put into
the game vrabel said not very he just
simply was listening to the play calls
that way okay well i know this when
marcus mariota came out in the third
quarter and all of a sudden was like a
guy who'd been
shocked into consciousness
i couldn't help but wonder
as he was driving the team down the
field on that drive that ultimately
ended in a fourth down play at the goal
line that didn't make it
did he get some sort of an indication in
the locker room that maybe he's got a
problem maybe he's got an issue maybe
there's going to be a benching in the
offing if he doesn't snap out of his
funk and he did
at least for the third quarter i was
very concerned by the lack of urgency
from marcus mariota and the entire
tennessee offense in the fourth quarter
down 20 to seven half of the quarter to
go
trying to drive down the field too slow
to the line of scrimmage too slow to get
the ball snapped and you know what if
it's the others who are lollygagging and
not moving quickly enough it's on marcus
mariota to demand that they do what they
are expected to do in those moments and
get their ass to the line of scrimmage
and get ready and get moving because
they have to show a greater sense of
urgency when they're down by two scores
it's almost like they were conceding
and that's not good enough and at some
point if this continues ryan tannehill
is going to get a chance to show what he
can do because they're going to have to
evaluate him and what he brings to the
table in making a decision about 2020
once they get to the point if they get
to the point where they begin to decide
that maybe marcus mariota is not the
long-term answer
leonard fournette apparently isn't the
long-term answer running back for the
jacksonville jaguars i thought he was
going to be great this year sims agreed
with me i got him in both my fantasy
teams nobody cares
let me tell you something
i and and i i say this
hesitantly because it takes a
significant amount of courage to put on
that uniform and walk onto that field
and be out there with the biggest
strongest fastest athletes that
the united states of america has to
offer now look i know you could say well
basketball players talk
the full package all the different
skills there's no athlete like a
professional football player especially
from the standpoint of the
violence that can be inflicted upon you
when you're out there so it takes a high
degree of courage to just be on the
field with that said
i feel like leonard fernett doesn't want
to get hit i feel like he gets the ball
and you never have those dreams where
you're in slow motion and everybody else
is moving at normal speed and no matter
what you do you're like running in mud i
feel like leonard fournette every time
he gets the ball he goes from running in
mud to bracing for impact instead of
delivering the blow now there was one
point last night where he delivered a
nice blow uh and it said there were
flashes he had the long run near the end
of the game but not enough it's not
sustained it's not consistent he's
always been that way you know he'd have
a big run to pad his stats but the grind
it out
process just it's not good enough and i
thought he'd be significantly better
this year he's not and that's another
decision that the jaguars are gonna have
to make do they keep him for the fourth
year of his contract remember there's a
pending fight over his guaranteed money
and the jaguars have attacked it they've
tried to void it it's subject to an
arbitration it hasn't been resolved yet
but it could make it a lot easier for
the jaguars to move on for leonard
fournette next year if they decide this
guy is simply not getting it done and
based on what we saw last night even
though the jaguars won he is not getting
it done and he's a guy that they took
in the
first round of the 2017 draft with the
likes of patrick mahomes and desean
watson and christian mccaffrey on the
board all right jalen ramsey your first
round pick of the jacksonville jaguars
who seems to be moving toward the
conclusion of his career there and if
i'm the jaguars i keep this guy and even
if he's been traded the moment you hear
this it's a mistake for the jaguars to
have traded jaylen ramsey no different
than the mistake the raiders made last
year when they traded khalil mack you
use those draft picks to get great
players and when you have managed to
scratch off a lottery ticket and get a
winner you don't trade the winner in for
two more lottery tickets you keep the
winner now you got to pay the winner
that's the difference the jackpot
doesn't go to you
the jackpot goes to the player but you
have the benefit of having the great
player and the jaguar should work this
out and based upon his comments to nate
burleson uh from a podcast earlier this
week and those comments emerged
not a not an hour or two before the game
last night
i think if they would show up with a
giant bag of cash
that would go a long way toward
convincing jaylen ramsey that they want
him you know the financial commitment
you make to someone says plenty about
what you think of them and unless and
until the jaguars make a gigantic
financial commitment to jaylen ramsey
he's not going to believe that they want
him so
if you want him to think you want him
jacksonville
pay the man shot khan the owner of the
team seems to want to keep jaylen ramsey
very easy to do
write
a big
check
today
it's that simple now if you're going to
trade him this is where this gets
fascinating because there haven't been
many situations like this where there's
an elite player who's available this
early in a season while teams are still
trying to jockey to figure out where
they are and who they're competing with
and how they're going to try to get to
the playoffs and through the playoffs
into the super bowl and there's value in
dangling jaylen ramsey now because think
of it if you're the chiefs
are you gonna be more likely to give up
what the jaguars want to keep him away
from the ravens or maybe the patriots if
you're the seahawks do you give up more
because
if you get him you also keep him away
from the rams or the 49ers if they get
involved or other teams you'll be
competing with the cowboys right the
cowboys have to worry about the eagles
getting jaylen ramsey so do the cowboys
figure out a way to get jalen ramsey and
if the cost is two first-round picks if
you're confident you're going to be
drafting at the bottom of round one each
in the next two years good
it's like a high second round pick and
it's a small price to pay if if i were
to tell you that you could get jaylen
ramsey in the draft for a low first
round pick and to ensure that he will be
jaylen ramsey you have to give up
another low first round pick you do it
in a heartbeat now the difference is you
don't get to benefit from the early
years of that first round picks contract
where he's getting peanuts in comparison
to market value but
the whole purpose of the game is to have
the best players and jaylen ramsey if
he's available i could see if the
jaguars play this right
and they don't get too greedy just sit
back and let the auction play out
there's gonna be one team that gets
impulsive there's gonna be one team that
gets nervous there's gonna be one team
that says we gotta have this guy in part
because we want him and in part because
we don't want one of the teams that will
be standing in our way on the path to
miami to get him
right the patriots a couple of weeks ago
got receiver antonio brown and the
question now becomes how long will they
keep him i was very troubled by the
story that i saw last night from robert
klemko of si.com containing the group
text messages that's how warped this guy
is antonio brown he sends intimidating
and harassing text messages in a group
that apparently included his lawyer
and and folks
i've seen some people who have suggested
this really wasn't all that harassing
he's talking about how this woman who
has
accused antonio brown unofficially not
to the nfl not in a civil lawsuit not to
the police
just in a story to robert klemco told
the story of antonio brown showing up
while she was painting a mural at his
house wearing nothing but
a strategically placed hand towel
and you know look in comparison to the
lawsuit that was filed last week
this isn't nearly as troubling the
lawsuit from last week significant
sexual assault rape
despicable acts if true this
not in the same ballpark still
unacceptable but here's the thing
for antonio brown to reach out to this
person on a group text that included his
own lawyer for crying out loud and
suggest she's just trying to get money
suggest that she's broke show a picture
of her kids that he took a screenshot of
from her instagram account this is all
aimed at keeping her from transforming
the unofficial complaint against antonio
brown into an official complaint this is
about getting her to let it go and leave
him alone and not look for money and
more importantly not look to go to the
league office and spend ten hours
with the league talking about the things
antonio brown did like brittany taylor
did on monday
only six days after she had filed her
lawsuit
and
i
it's a weird setting it's a strange
context because you know when i
practiced law i would be involved in
investigations in a workplace where
you've got somebody from one
department and somebody from another
department and somebody's making an
accusation of misconduct and it's a
given in that setting that the person
who is accused of wrongdoing cannot
retaliate against the person who is
making the accusations or any of the
witnesses who may be saying anything
that would tend to show that the person
who is accused of wrongdoing did it it's
very simple it's very basic and and when
the investigation starts just to be
clear you would say
to the accused look
have no contact at all
with the person who's accusing you this
have no contact with any of the
witnesses if there's any sign of any
type of retaliation or harassment you
will be fired on the spot
um
and in the nfl setting see the workplace
isn't
you know the the scranton office park
where dunder mifflin is on the third
floor wherever they were the the
workplace is the whole world
because
you're subject to the personal conduct
policy wherever you are whenever you are
on the clock off the clock in the
stadium out of the stadium in season out
of season in the country out of the
country you're subject to the personal
conduct policy so if there's someone out
there
who has made it clear that she's got
information that would suggest you
violated the personal conduct policy and
you begin trying to intimidate her
trying to get her to let it go and not
cause a problem for you with your
employer
cries out for action
and from the nfl's perspective they have
the power to suspend antonio brown
and from the patriots perspective they
can cut him anytime they want
and it's correct that the patriots
wouldn't have signed antonio brown if
they knew about the lawsuit nobody would
have
nobody would have that that lawsuit gets
filed on a monday there's no way antonio
brown gets signed on tuesday but he got
signed on monday and the lawsuit showed
up on tuesday and it would be horrible
precedent to fire a guy based simply on
the uncorroborated allegations contained
in a civil lawsuit because anyone can
file a civil lawsuit whatever the filing
fee is 250 bucks 300 bucks 500 bucks i
don't know it's not all that expensive
to get a lawsuit started you can make
any allegation you want now your lawyer
is going to be subject to potential
sanction if it's a frivolous lawsuit but
that provision rarely ever gets applied
people can sue for anything they want
whenever they want and then it's up to
the court system to decide what to do
with it
so you can't fire somebody based simply
on that
but
when you start to see these other
incidents specifically an act of
intimidation and harassment directed at
somebody who would be inclined to
potentially make a formal claim of
misconduct against antonio brown that's
when it becomes a problem that's when
you have enough if you're the patriots
it's more than than just saying well we
can't fire the guy based on a civil
lawsuit now you've got
this smoking gun
of intimidation and harassment and look
there's other stuff out there we may not
know about i've said all week 10 hours
brittany taylor with the nfl what did
she say how persuasive was she how much
of that did the patriots know about what
kind of investigation have the patriots
been doing on their own if if i'm robert
kraft i want to know
what i'm dealing with i want to know who
this guy is he's been accused in a civil
action that's not enough to take action
against him but it's enough to put me on
notice that i should use some of my
resources to figure out exactly who i'm
dealing with because if this goes
sideways it's going to reflect poorly on
the patriots and yes they're at a point
now where they may have to write off
nine million dollars but the nine
million dollars that they give up in
moving on from antonio brown could pale
in comparison to the damage that keeping
him could do to their brand
so
look it's now uh 1006 a.m eastern as i
say these words i won't be surprised if
he's on the commissioner exemplist by
the end of the day and i won't be
surprised if the patriots cut him by the
end of the day that's how alarming these
intimidating and harassing text messages
are to me we'll see if the patriots
agree we'll see if the league agrees and
we'll see you next week for pft live and
pft ot enjoy the week three games and
we'll talk to you soon